Terrorism is very scary,
especially when it happens close to home and not in some far away place.
Nobody likes to be afraid and we were eager to make the fear go away,
so we demanded more security in the last decade.
It's become increasingly normal for civil liberties to be eroded and for
government agencies to spy on citizens to collect and store their personal
information.
Regardless of whether you're a fan of right or left wing policies.
This affects every one of us,
so we have to take a look at the data and ask ourselves honestly,
has all of this actually made us safer?
In the aftermath of nine 11 the u s government concluded that the law had not
kept pace with technology.
It created the terrorist surveillance program initially to intercept
communications linked to al Qaeda officials.
We're confident that if the program had been in place before nine 11 the
hijackers could have been stopped,
but soon the new powers were also used to prove guilt by association.
The FBI used immigration records to identify Arab Muslim foreign nationals in
the u s on their spaces.
80,000 individuals were required to register.
Another 8,000 were called in for FBI interviews and more than 5,000 locked up in
preventive detention.
Not One terrorist was found in what's been called the most aggressive national
campaign of ethnic profiling since world war two how colon pace it's since
become for government agencies to collect and store the personal data of
citizens was made plain by the leak of the Snowden documents.
In 2013 they showed how the NSE can demand information about users from firms
like Microsoft or Google.
In addition to that daily collection of data from civilian internet traffic such
as email content and contact lists.
So instead of focusing on criminals,
governments are increasingly turning their attention to everyone.
But if you're looking for a needle in a haystack,
adding more hay to the stack isn't going to make it any easier to find the
needle.
On the contrary,
every recent success announced by the NSA has come from classic targets
surveillance,
despite high hopes,
the NSA surveillance program has not stopped any major terror attack.
For instance,
one of the Boston marathon bombers was already a target of the FBI.
So what we need is not even more random data,
but better ways to understand and use the information we have.
Spy agencies are also pushing to cripple encryption.
In early 2016 the FBI asks apple to produce her backdoor program to disabled the
encryption of a terrorist.
Iphone.
Apple publicly declined not only because there's tool could be used to
permanently weakened the privacy of law abiding citizens worldwide,
but a fair into open the floodgates for governments requesting access to a
technology used by billions of people,
a fair shared by security experts,
and
a few weeks later the FBI revealed that they had had the phone themselves
basically admitting that they lied to the public about the need for a backdoor.
Which questions?
How trustworthy spy agencies are in the debate about privacy and security,
especially considering that the NSA,
for example,
already has the capability to turn on your iPhone microphone or activate your
laptop camera without you noticing.
Concerns about this are often met with the argument.
If you have nothing to hide,
you have nothing to fear that this reasoning only creates a climate of
oppression wanting to keep certain parts of your life private.
It doesn't mean you're doing anything wrong right now.
We live in a democracy,
but imagine the damage the wrong person could do with all our data and such.
Easy access to our devices.
Antiterrorism laws allow the authorities to investigate and punish and lawn
terrorism related crimes more aggressively.
If you give law enforcement powerful tools,
they will use them.
That's why democratic oversight is so important.
Even if those tools and laws aren't used against you today,
they might meet tomorrow.
For example,
following the November,
2015 Paris attacks,
France expanded.
It's already extensive antiterrorism laws by giving law enforcement greater
powers to conduct house rate and pace people under house arrest.
Within weeks,
evidence emerged that these powers were being used for unintended purposes such
as causing climate change protests.
The governments of Spain,
Hungary and Poland have introduced more restrictive laws on the freedom of
assembly and speech,
freedom of expression,
and the press in Turkey has been seriously undermined in the last few years with
people sentenced to prison for criticizing the government.
None of this is effectively helping us fight terrorism.
The motivation behind this might be good,
even noble,
but if we let our elected governments limit our personal freedom,
the terrorists are winning.
What's worse?
If we're not careful,
we might slowly move towards a surveillance state.
The data is pretty clear.
The erosion of rights along with mass surveillance hasn't led to significant
successes so far,
but it has changed the nature of our society.
Terrorism is a complicated problems.
Without simple solutions,
no security operators can prevent a few guys from building a bomb in that
basement.
We should keep the principle of proportionality in mind.
Creating master keys to enter millions of phones is not the same as searching a
single house in most countries.
The law already permits a wide range of actions,
including targeted surveillance to take full advantage of this existing
potential.
We need better international corporation and more effective security and foreign
policies,
better application of our present laws instead of new and stricter ones that
undermine our freedom.
Let us not out of fear,
destroy what we are most proud of,
democracy and our fundamental and the parties.
This video was made possible by your support on pitch on.com and the European
liberty's platform,
liberty's dot EU.